[موسيقى]
ذا وا الطريق الى
سانجين دي سانتياجو ذا واي فيلم الطريق هو
فيلم موجود قبل خمس سنين تقريبا ليالي من
ليالي الكليه كان عندي امتحان نهائي كان
المفروض ادرس واقرا واحضر واكون مستعد
للامتحان بس بمكان ما اسوي الاشيا كلها
اكيد اخذت الطريق اللي يعني دائما متعود
عليه ان الهي نفسي باشياء وابتعد عن
الدراسه فتهيت بهذا الفيلم فيلم ما كنت
اعرفه وشفته بالصدفه استهواني عجبتني
الكلمات القصيره المكتوبه عنه بلشت اتفرجه
بعد لحظات لقيت نفسي ملتصق بالشاشه متابعه
بانتباه
الفيلم يتحدث عن مسيره كمينا دي سانتياجو
الا وهي حج مسيره حج كاثوليكيه الاصل بها
صبغه مسيحيه بها صبغه دينيه روحانيه وايضا
ثقافيه في السنين
الاخيره حبيت الفكره حبيت ها المسيره حبيت
ها المشيه استهوتني جدا انا تركت العراق
منذ اكثر من ع سنين ومن يوم اللي تركت
العراق الى اليوم احنل العراق اكيد واحده
من الاشياء اللي تعلمتها بالمجتمع الخارجي
وخاصه بامريكا اكتشفت انه صوره العراق
والعراقيين جدا مشوهه هاي الصوره ما يصلهم
للغرب فقط هي الحروب والعنف والارهاب وهذا
الشيء يعني اذاني بطريقه جدا قويه ما
مستحيل اقبل به فاخذتها على صعد او على
صعيد شخصي ان اتكفل بهذا الموضوع على
امكانياتي وقدراتي البسيطه انا احاول احسن
هاي الصوره بالقدر اللي اقدر عليه كمينو
دي سانتياجو وهاي المسيره بدات
كمسرح ممتاز انا اوصل رساله حب وسلام من
العراقيين والعراق الى بقيه
العالم المسيره تمتد حوالي 850 ر تمتد من
جنوب فرنسا الى شمال غرب اسبانيا والمسيره
مشيناها مشيا على الاقدام هاي المده
المسافه كلها استغرقت عندي حوالي 27 يوم
انا كنت امشي سريع بهذا المشي تقدر تمشي
انت منفرد ولوحدك او تقدر تمشي ويا اصحاب
ويا جماعات حسب كل من
وتفضيله هو شلون يصير فعاده انا كنت اطلع
بالاربعه الصبح يعني اطلع من المكان احنا
اللي كنا نبات به يسموه البر البر تقدرون
تتخيلوها مثل البنقله او مث مضيف بسيط في
قريوت كنا ننام ب و بالبر من اط اطلع من
الفجر ونبدي نمشي الى ان اوصل القريه
الجايه اللي ابات بها الاقي هوايه ناس
الاقي هوايه شعوب الاقي هوايه ناس من كل
انحاء العالم اللي ما يوم توقعت انه راح
تربطني صله وياهم راح تربطني علاقه وياهم
وبالاخص ما كنت متوقع انه راح يربطني حاضر
بهم وممكن تتسائلون شنو اقصد بهذا الحاضر
نبذه عن الناس اللي التقيت بهم التقيت
بشخص اسمه هاي الصوره التقيت بشخص هذول من
الاشخاص اللي لقيتهم بالطريق في كثير من
الناس التقيت هذا الشخص اسمه ميك ميك
جيرارد رجل استرالي عايش باستراليا انا
حده من القرى اللي وصلت لها اسمها تري
كاست معناها القلاع الثلاث بهاي القريه
انا سامع بالطريق قالوا هذول يعرفون يسوون
باتشا الباتشا يسموها كبيزه باسبانيا
فقالوا يعرفون يسوون باتشا وانا مشتهي
باتشا واحب الباشه فقلت اوصل لازم
اكل طلعت العصر ب نروح نتعشى بمطعم او فشي
والقى هذا الرجال قاعد ياكل باشا حسب
الاصول هو مثل ما تشوفوا عيونه زرق مبين
كان اناش قراني يعني مو مال يعرف باتشا
فقررت اتحار به شويه واسال عن هذا
الموضوع خلال تعرفوا على افتهمت انه والد
مك هو كان جندي بريطاني بالعراق في زمن
الحكم البريطاني قبل تقريبا 100 سنه والد
مك كان جدا
متاثر بالحضاره والثقافه العراقيه و
والحمد لله والشكر وصل الى مك وابنه وبقيه
العائله بصوره جدا طيبه عن العراق
والعراقيين واحده من الاشياء اللي عشقوها
هم الفشا والاكل العراقي ومك حتى كان يعرف
السمك المسقوف وقال احنا حاولنا نسويه
باستراليا بس ابوي يقول الطعم ماكو منه
اثاري هو كان ده يحكي عن الكارب مك واحده
من الشخصيات اللي التقيت بها اللي مثل ما
قلت انا ما كنت في يوم اتوقع القى شخص راح
تربطني ب ثقافه وحضاره تاريخيه اني انتمي
لها وهو يعرف
عنها من ضمن الاشخاص اللي ايضا تعرفت
عليهم هي زوجه ميك كيرين وهاي الصوره لهم
اثنينهم سوري الصوره هي شوي اذا ممكن نرجع
سلايد الصوره هي شوي مغوش انا كنت امشي
وراهم واخذتها بتليفوني فطلعت مغبشه زوجه
مك كيرين امريه كانت مصابه بمرض السرطان
وكانت عندها معضلات صحيه جدا قويه الاطباء
استبعدوا فرصها بالحياه استبعدوا فرصها
بالمشي ولكن بالدعم المعنوي اللي حصلته من
عائلتها والاصدقاء هي قدرت بعد تقريبا
اشهر من التشخيص الخاطئ للاطباء انه تيجي
تمشي هاي المسيره ويانا مسيره 850 ك مر
امراه في منتصف الخمسينيات بدايه
الستينيات مشتها رغم المرض بس هي اخذتها
تحدي لها وكملت الموضوع ومشت بها ما عندها
اي
مشكله مكو كير جدا لطيفي من
هاي حبيت اعرفكم عنهم ل حتى تكون اكو فكره
الاسباب بالمشي بهاي
المسيره الشخص الجاي اللي بعدها اذا ممكن
هذا الانسان اسمه برنارد رجل ايرلندي وجدا
لطيف وفكاهي وهذا كان ده يمشي مشي انا كلش
استغربت لما يعني فرحت واستغربت لما سمعت
السبب هو كان مواعد اخوه اخوه توفى قبل
اكثر من خمس سنين من من تاريخ المسيره
ووعد اخوه انه يمشي لهي المسيره والحجه
باسمه فهو كان يستخدم جواز اخوه واسم اخوه
بال المسيره كلها وانا هذا الشيء جدا فرحت
به لانه وضح لي انه احنا عندنا بثقافتنا
اشياء احنا نسوي
موجوده هي ايضا بالعالم فلذلك اكتشفت انه
احنا ممكن كنا يعني احنا كنا ابناء لوطن
واحد الا وهو
الانسانيه كثره الاسباب اللي الناس تمشي
بها الطريق واكيد انا الي اسبابي ف اذا
ممكن السلايد شباب
شكرا فانا الي اسبابي بالمسير ايضا فلما
كانوا يسالوني انت حمزه ليش تمشي فجواب
كان دائما يكون انا جاي امشي بالدعاء
للسلام للعراق
والعراقيين هذا الجواب كان يخلق حب فضول
صار عندهم حب المعرفه والتعمق بهالموضوع
يريدون يعرفون عن الحياه اليوميه
للعراقيين عن هاي عن هذا البلد شنو شنو
اللي يدفع شنو اللي يسويه فيساله اسئله
هوايه وانا كنت اترحم واتمنى يسالون ها
الاسئله حتى اوصل
معلوماتي من يسالون ومن نتعمق بهذ هي ها
كانت فرصتي ان اوصل كلام واوصل صوره هي
مغايره للي يعرفوه واح احاول اتمنى ان
اغير رايهم والحمد لله نجحت بهذا الشيء
هنا انا كنت احدثهم عن دجله والفرات هنا
كنت احدثهم عن الفنانين الرسامين الثقافه
الحضاره الموجوده عندنا هنا كنت احدثهم عن
الغيره والروح العراقيه اللي ما موجوده
باي مكان اخر بالعالم هنا كنت احدثهم احنا
كيف نساعد الغريب كيف احنا نساعد بعضنا
البعض علاقات الجيران مع مع بعضهم هاي
الاشياء ما موجوده بالخارج ما موجوده باي
مكان هاي فقط بالروح العراقيه والشيء اللي
الابدع بالموضوع الا وهي هاي الصفات وهاي
الروح ما دامت موجوده ولا زالت موجوده هي
اذا اكو بصيص امل للتطور الثقافي
الاجتماعي
والحضاري ما دامت هاي العادات وهاي الروح
عايشه بينا اذا احنا مو ممكن نتقدم وممكن
نتوصل ونصير من احسن بلدان العالم لانه
طيبت قلوبنا
وعراقه ثقافتنا ما لها سابق ولا لها
مثيل بهاي القصص كلها كان الناس جدا
يتاثرون كان احس يتعاطفون وياي يتعاطفون
كاني ابنهم كاني منهم وبيه يتعاطفون مع
العراق كانه بلدهم كانوا يشعرون بالخجل
بالحرج لعدم معرفتهم بهذا الشيء اصلا يعني
يعتذرون يقول يقول احنا اسفين بس ما
توصلنا ها الاخبار احنا ايش قد كيفنا
سمعنا من عندك هذا الشيء ويقولوا احنا
نوعدك احنا من نوصل رح نحدث الناس عن هذا
الشيء نوصل ها الرساله لاهلنا واصدقائنا
هناك لانه لازم هذا الشيء نصحح هذا الخطا
هاي الصوره الغير صحيحه
ام من من نوصل احنا دائما همينا من نمشي
لازم بالمسير نحصل اختام من كنائس كل ما
نمشي اذا اكو صوره الشباب ممكن هذا جواز
المسيره فهذا ختم من كل كنيسه من نوصل
للدنش الاخير المكان الاخير يشوفوه يعطونا
شهاده انه مشينا فبهذا المكان دائما اكو
رهبان وراهبات بالكنيسه هم يديرون هذا
الشيء ويعطون الختم فيسال وك انت ليش تمشي
فلما نعطيهم الجواب كانوا يعني يبكون
صدقوني كانوا يبكون كانه العراق بلدهم و
بيهم حرقه بقلبهم يتعذرون على الاوضاع
اللي احنا نمور بها بعد هاي المحادثات
وياهم كانوا يدعون الناس الى الى يقومون
بقداس وقت العصر فيجون يعني يسووا له
دعايه يقولون يابا اللي يجي ترى احنا
الساعه اعه العصر راح نسوي قداس دعاء
للسلام للعراق انا كنت اول الحاضرين
للقداس اكيد وما ما يحتاج ما اعرف شلون
اوصلكم مشاعري شنو كانت ما اقدر اوصفها بس
لما كنت اوصل كنت اشوف عشرات اذا مو مئات
الناس يجون الى كنيسه صغيره بسيطه في قريه
بعد ما مشوا ها المسافات كلها يدعون
للسلام للعراق والعراقيين موقف وصور ما
اعجز عن وصفها بالكلمات ما اعرف شلون
اوصلها
فاعذروني هاي
التجربه كانت تجربه جدا غنيه الي بحياتي
الشخصيه وبنفس الوقت انا جدا سعيد سنحت لي
فرصه ان اقوم بها ان اوصل هاي الرساله
اتمنى انه اقدر اوصل ها الرساله انا
اوعدكم انا على قابليات وعلى قدراتي استمر
بهذا الشيء اتمنى السلام بلدنا العراق
اتمنى السلام
للجميع الدرس الاكبر اللي تعلمته من ها
المسيره انه احنا كلنا بغض النظر عن
الديانات والاختلافات والدول اللي نجي
منها احنا كلنا نجتمع تحت خيمه الانسانيه
وهاي خيمه الانسانيه تحوينا وكلنا من
ابنائها وان شاء الله تستمر وان شاء الله
العراق من احسن الى احسن
[تصفيق]
شكرا
l